ce sont peut-être les futurs terminaux
de la police le fruit d'un partenariat
entre airbus et la start-up united
biometrics créé en 2014 est incubé sur
le plateau de saclay cette entreprise
est spécialisée dans la sécurité des
accès numérique avec de la biométrie
notamment la reconnaissance faciale
voilà donc là on voit le mas sur lequel
je dois donc porter mon visage et donc
je me suis authentifié sur la machine et
on vous avez vu que j'ai dû donc bouger
la tête cette solution a été intégrée
dans les terminaux fabriqués par airbus
le groupe a rencontré cette start up au
salon viva tech avant de l'inviter pour
un pitch de présentation sur le site
on pensait l'intégrer dans des projets
de cybersécurité en fait c'est des gens
qui font des terminaux de communication
pour la police qui ont trouvé la brique
qui leur manquait pour mettre de la
biométrie et sécuriser les futurs
terminaux de demain qui vont être livrés
à la place beauvau airbus possède
plusieurs outils dans sa stratégie
d'open innovation en 2017 des
collaborateurs ont créé lee lab un
espace de créativité
d'abord destiné aux ingénieurs en
interne il s'ouvre ensuite aux
entreprises extérieures alors en interne
l'idée ça a été vraiment de d'organiser
des challenge pour pousser l'équipe
acquérir de nouvelles compétences dans
un mode très collaboratif et puis créé
en 1996 le réseau r'bus développement
permet au groupe de tisser des liens
avec des entreprises en 2010 835
partenariats ont été signés
plus de 250 start up ont été accompagnés
pour airbus ces innover pour airbus
développement dans notre rôle
territoriale et sociétal c'est de
pousser à la création d'emplois
réindustrialiser sur les régions
le flux annuel est en croissance cette
année on va avoir 160 start-up nouvelle
donc on pense que d'ici deux à trois ans
notre stock va passer de 250 à 500 des
collaborations ouverte sur l'europe
cette année airbus a noué des liens avec
cette start up allemande et espagnole